as you have tracked this Gina from the
time this started until now and compared
to even 20 years ago 30 years ago what
have you seen change not a hell of a lot
there really not a lot the number of
female characters the ratio of male to
female characters is pretty much still
the same pretty much still the same as
it was starting in 1946 when it was
better before but that's when Betty
Davis did all the roles right what's
that Betty Davis had all the roles right
right exactly but but obviously there is
some project progress and and TV is
doing a much better job in front of an
behind the camera and there's there's
some pockets of improvement characters
are more hyper sexualized than they were
20 years ago if now female characters
between 13 and 39 are equally sexualized
which is kind of grim news looking at at
the imbalance that you showed and that
goes to one of the most important parts
of the story is the data you can say
anecdotes - you're blue in the face but
the data will knock you back in your
seat did it astonish you when you got
some of these numbers as you were
putting this film together oh yeah
absolutely I mean the data I originally
when I started this in 2015 I should
probably talk about why a man directed
this right okay so when I was 10 years
old I grew up in a very right-wing
family and you know they loved Nixon and
Reagan that's all I knew and it was the
power of media when I was you know this
little box that really showed me there
could be another world and that was
really the worker like Norman Lear all
in the family was like that was my dad
and then I saw a show called mash and it
changed my life and Alan Alda was my
hero and the more I learned about Alan
Alda is that he called himself something
that in my family was a bad word and
that was feminist and yet he said it he
wore it proudly like a badge and I was
amazed by that I'm like how can a man
call himself a feminist it's so
embarrassing and I learned more about it
I learned about Marlo Thomas and Gloria
Steinem in the Equal Rights Amendment
and understood that you know women
didn't have equal rights to men
and this is at the age of 10 so then I
made a movie called casting by which was
going to be originally oh thank you
about a casting director named Marion
Dougherty and I remember sitting down
with Marion Dougherty on the couch in
2007 when I started and I said you know
she goes were the only main title credit
that doesn't have its own Oscar and I
was like why and she goes well were 75
percent female and that's why so I was I
was introduced into the roadblocks that
women face in Hollywood by making this
movie that was supposed to just be a
tribute to a casting director I realized
an entire profession had been
stigmatized
because it was majority female so those
two things together and a publicist who
came to me in 2015 and said would you
consider doing a documentary on the
larger issues that women face in
Hollywood and my producing partner Alana
Arboleda who's a male and I having just
made a film about failed mental health
policy in the US military where we were
not veterans realized our duty here as
men and as American citizens that this
is a problem this is social injustice
this is a civil rights issue that
affects everyone and that allows us to
have the leadership now the toxic
masculinity and the level of of horrible
white supremacist toxic masculinity that
has gone around the world now and I
think because of the gender imbalance
it's put our planet in danger so I
thought we are all responsible to fix
this and we all have to step up and
actually help to make the change so I
didn't think twice that I shouldn't make
this movie and was happy to to start on
that journey and a year later so
originally it was going to be about
workplace discrimination and that data
was important to us and I realized for
this to appeal to a more general
audience and worldwide I had to explain
that a lot of what happens behind the
scenes in Hollywood has an outsized
impact on everybody around the world and
that's when I learned about what Gina
did and what her Institute was doing and
I knew in 2016 that I needed to get Gina
to come on board and let me tell her
story because that was the other half of
the film so I pitched to Gina and in
Gina said yes so when you start getting
data from your Institute were you taken
aback was it
person you had even thought once it was
all codified no I thought it was pretty
horrific before I had the data but it
was so bizarre that I couldn't find
anybody else who noticed what seemed
like an incredibly glaring and horrible
problem you know that we would be
teaching kids from the beginning to have
unconscious gender bias so it was very
shocking that no one seemed to have
recognized this until I had the data but
but it was all pretty bad it was you
know it's it's just all bad and and now
we have a new tool that can with a face
and voice recognition and artificial
intelligence that can tell you how much
screen time and how much speaking time
characters have and that's also horrible
so there's not only fewer female
characters but they are on screen and
talk less in fact when there's a female
a movie with a female lead she's on
screen and talks half as much as the
male lead of a movie and where is the
easiest point to enter to break that
circle where is it a woman director who
can bring other people on board is it at
the the script writing stage or is it a
big-name
actor who says no I want X Y & Z I think
Studios need to have a policy where when
they have lists of Directors it's 5050
not even 40 60 just 50/50 half female
half men and find the female directors
cuz they're out there they're really
talented they're in the pipeline it's
just that they don't get hired so the
studios have to make a conscious effort
to change that can you elaborate on how
the CSI effect actually works in film
and in television the scully affect me
yeah and well we just did that's not in
the movie right the skull effect so Fox
asked us to do a research study on the
Scully effects through the x-files that
you know the TV show The X Files to find
out what impact the Dana Scully
character had on women's career choices
and we found it was lots of fascinating
numbers but
63% of women working in STEM fields now
site specifically dana scully as their
inspiration for going into the job they
have 63% and I talked about the archery
thing on them in the movie right so it's
like you show it on screen and it
happens it just happens in real life
it's like if we're thinking we have to
wait for society to turn around and then
we'll reflect that we're going about it
completely the wrong way because life
will imitate art we could do it first
and and it will be apprentice it will
happen in real life what's that like
they play you saw The Apprentice there
was one line and Jeana maybe you can
elaborate on this kimberly peirce said
men fail upward women succeed downward
weird where do you see this can you give
us some more examples oh god well I mean
her example is so excruciating it's a
it's a it's an embarrassment it's a it's
a shame on the industry that she would
make boys don't cry and then not work
again for 14 years I mean nine years Oh
Dinah patty Jenkins was 14 between patty
was 14 that's right oh my god both of
those are horrifying really an
embarrassment to our industry that
that's something like that could happen
but we all know I've heard about it read
about directors who have a movie that's
a big flop and they immediately just get
another one
but women can't but I mean her her
expression is just perfect you know that
you can be incredibly successful and and
never get hired again Tom you sound kind
of dispirited about the prospects for
change I just don't believe in
complacency I don't want to act like
things are changing is that I want
everyone to keep fighting so I'm not I'm
never someone to say oh everything's
changing for the better and something
you'll never hear me say gee you know
what about you our dude well I'm
cautiously optimistic frankly I think
that on-screen character on screen
representation is the lowest hanging
fruit and and children's TV and movies
is the on screen is the lowest hanging
fruit of all because the
who make kids entertainment or doing it
because they love kids and they care
about them and you know when we bring
our data to them they're appalled with
themselves they just cannot believe that
they couldn't see how few female
characters they were showing and how
they were not doing right by little
girls and it I think it will change
everything actually it will change a lot
if we can have kids grow up seeing boys
and girls sharing the sandbox equally
doing east equally interesting and
important things and both taking up half
the space in the world if we could see
that it will happen in real life how
much of this is unconscious because
people see the world as the white male
default yeah well I just saw a movie
here last Saturday night that was
egregious in his representation of women
that got a six minute standing ovation
it can yeah I won't say the name of it
but it was playing last Saturday night
and look at out I I was I was I thought
it was horrifying
and yet it's critically acclaimed and
everybody's blind to it's incredible
violence toward women in its treatment
of women so I think it's very
unconscious and it's very deeply
embedded in our culture going forward is
there a new metric a new awareness that
somebody at least will be tugging on a
coattail and saying hey you shouldn't be
doing it that well that's that's
progress in society and that happens
through the ages I guess right is it
happening oh yeah and you think the and
for eugenia the me2 movement that women
are beginning to connect the dots on all
of this it isn't just about politics it
isn't just about stem and the way little
girls are taught about science it's
sitting down in front of the television
when you're four years old and not
seeing anything of yourself there right
right absolutely yeah and and I do feel
that things you know I became very
cynical about progress every bidding
yeah being made but then when when me
too and times up and all that happened I
feel like we really are in a in a state
of progress right now or that something
has changed and the most apparent thing
to me is that it's now okay to talk
about all this look at everybody talking
about this and passionately and and
revealing you know ways that they were
discriminated against and and
shortchanged and abused and and all of
that and and I think that we all felt
earlier before all this happened that
the worst thing you could do ever would
be to complain that they'll just hire
somebody else and you certainly wouldn't
want to let on that you were sexually
harassed or that you were paid less
money or anything because you just
completely assumed well nobody will want
to work with me if I'm in any way the
slightest problem no L just won't hire
me well I do want to thank you both this
is a remarkable piece of filmmaking and
it really moved me and I'm sure there
will be millions of others who feel
exactly the same way